welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the crown the final part
of season 6 is now out and there's a lot
to talk about in it throughout this
video we're going to be going through it
all and breaking down the real life
stories behind each episode heavy
spoilers ahead so if you don't want it
ruined then I highly recommend that you
royally do one and come back after
you've seen the show one request that
you hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day out the way huge thank you for
this now let's get into the
[Music]
crown okay so part one saw both the lead
up and aftermath of Diana's death even
with the time Jump that still hangs
heavily over part two with William
struggling to deal with the grief of
losing his mother several people write
letters and though his family try to
comfort him it's clear there's no way
for him to easily get over it everyone
asks him how he's feeling but it's clear
that in the end he's just isolated and
alone alone the only person who
understands him is of course Harry and
we know how that would turn out due to
recent events Harry went off at his
brother quite a lot in his autobiography
spare with a show of course avoiding the
complexities of their relationship in
recent years that means that we don't
really see things with Megan but we do
get a lot with Kate Middleton girls are
throwing themselves at him and their
arrival at places is described like
being a pop star showing up however in
Katie finds someone he can relate to
with it sort of being in a similar vein
to Charles the seasons focused purely on
him and Diana of course always had
Camila being off in the background even
his parents didn't really support him
marrying her and William also kind of
blames his dad for what happened with
Diana he thinks that Diana still loved
him and only went to France to get away
from Camila's birthday so the finale
kind of brings things full circle and
shows that there was a level of
acceptance bringing it all together the
season ends in 2005 with his and
Camila's wedding which is a more
positive direction from what they they
could have done hey guess what very
excited to talk about today's sponsors
ag1 we've been using them for months now
I feel a hell of a lot better than
myself and yeah I'm very excited to work
with this brand and tell you about all
the benefits a1's the daily Health habit
that's filled with vitamins minerals
Whole Food sourced ingredients and
probiotics since having the kids and
send them to Nursery they've been
bringing back lots of diseases so I've
been looking for ways to boost my immune
system which is where ag1 come in it's a
simple supplement and with just one
scoop you get 75 vitamins and minerals
that replenish your daily nutrients and
leave you feeling better personally I
was also always drinking coffee all the
time like three cups a day at least but
this just gives me the energy that I
need throughout the day ag1 gives a
comprehensive nutrition supplement that
provides nutrients for your body brain
and good health and you're welcome kit
you'll get an ag1 pouch a refillable
canister AG vitamin D12 and K2 you'll
also get the ag1 travel pack shake a
bottle and a scoop as well it's very
simple just one scoop in give it a shake
and it also has a lovely vanilla R
pineapple flavor so it tastes great as
well I'm just so used to doing it now
it's become a daily Health habit but I
look forward to how it makes me feel cuz
it just starts off the day on the right
foot just go to the link in the
description click that and you're going
to get a year free supply of vitamin D3
and K2 plus five ag1 travel pouches with
your first purchase huge thank you to
ag1 for sponsoring this video just try
them out yeah because it's going to make
you feel more energized you'll feel
better on your body and yeah I
definitely recommend that you check them
out in the description thank you my part
two jumps back and forth a lot through
time and when we went to VA day I was
seeing what direction they were going
Crown no way home is what we get later
on but this early story it isn't so much
that and instead it involves V Day
namely when Margaret and Elizabeth snuck
out to the rits now according to the
reports this really happened and was
something the pair did at 19 and4
sneaking out in Disguise they were
accompanied by gods which is where the
par said to have danced The Night Away
the independent pointed out that King
George said it had been Margaret's idea
and that he was happy for the pair as
they hadn't really had much of a life
yet sadly Margaret passed away in 2002
after suffering a stroke and cardiac
problems the health issues are
documented in episode a along with one
of her last public appearances these
happen at her mother's 101st birthday
celebrations in August her birthday in
the same month and lastly the 100th
birthday of Princess Alice which
happened in December part one got
criticized a lot for the use of quote
unquote ghosts in it but I think the way
they handle ANS passing at the end of
episode 8 it works way better although
they take a lot of Liberty with the
truth the crown has always has some
aspects based in reality Will's Mania
deals with Will's feelings on his
mother's death whereas the ninth Century
Hope Street is Operation padet that came
in the wake of allegations that doy and
Diana were murdered which were levied by
Muhammad alfed now if you live in the UK
or well anywhere and kept up with her
death then you'll probably be aware of
the conspiracy theories that have since
surrounded it it was s Philip had
arranged for the murder because Diana
was pregnant with D's child this was
then apparently covered up by the powers
that be with no one ever being blamed
specifically for their deaths now to add
some dramatic tension the show has a
report coming out ahead of the Queen's
Jubilee but if you live through it
you'll probably remember that didn't
happen the inquiry didn't get set up
until 2004 with it finally wrapping up
in 2008 this found everything to be down
to an accident in and that Diana wasn't
also pregnant at the time it stated that
the main factors were that the driver
Henry Paul had been drinking and that
neither of the deceased had been wearing
a seat belt lastly they couldn't find
evidence of a cover up and there's
nothing ever really came from it still
though in the show paints out how the
Jubilee had some controversy around it
with episode 7 diving heavily into that
there were peer reviews and polls on the
Royals with the majority seeming like
they were completely out of favor with
them however as we know the Royals have
remained something wildly talked about
with the jubilees incarnations being big
events still though the Queen's fear
that they might be outed is represented
in episode 6 when she has a nightmare
Tony Blair is going to be crowned the
king kill me like I was thinking what
what the hell am I watching when the new
national anthem was things can only get
better that was by the band dream or
dream which it's clever yeah cuz cuz
she's having a dream now dear me now not
only does this show the Queen's a dream
fan but it also show she fears Blair's
more popular this was shown in real life
in the polls 2 with the Royals being
described as a big waste of money Blair
brings us up to the queen during episode
six with him listing off the pointless
jobs that they just waste money on
things like a swan God napkin folder
YouTuber and film reviewer wait what the
what the hell is this anyway this is a
conversation that of course remains
relevant with the cost of living crisis
making people continue to ask it still
though the roals themselves must wor too
with these polls being something that
happened as well the independent noted
that labor carried out a private poll
that showed Blair's popularity shut up
93% in the wake of Diana's death however
we see how this wains with the women's
Institute with a queen speech there
going down a storm blaz doesn't which is
something that happened in real life
with it being the start of his downfall
the crowd do a big slow clap which is
also something that got well documented
the organizers apparently had to tell
them to stop doing it but even then it
did go down well in the House of Commons
he also got mocked for this too and it's
often thought to be something that
signaled the beginning of the end from
this point Blair was lambasted for being
out of touch and he ended up residing in
the wake of his actions in the Iraq War
now who was popular or still is I don't
know may head headlines change every
week but who was popular is or William
and Kay with several of their meetings
being shown throughout that includes
what said to be the first time they saw
each other which involved di as well
episode 7 shows them selling the big
issue but that situation is completely
made up though Williams being a vocal
supporter of it the pair didn't meet
until they attended University so Kate
sitting at home cutting photos out of
him like some absolute nutcase not not
sure it happened but yeah at least from
what we know they didn't meet there now
part one had Muhammad desperately trying
to set up Dy and die with that role here
going to Kate's mother Carol played by
Eve best you might recognize her from
another show involving royalty the
independent noted that Omid scobby book
endgame did claim Carol Carol ulated
ways to set the pair up and this
included everything along with The Gap
yet now the show is William and Kate
both dating others with Kate's man being
called ruper Finch in real life this
ruper did exist but I couldn't find
anyone called Lola for William whether
that's the case or not I'm not sure but
he did date someone called Olivia hunt K
provides a way for him to escape the
Royal Institution and it sees him
spending the Jubilee Day with her this
comes off the back of the death of the
queen mother which was known as
operation tap Elizabeth's death would
become known as operation London Bridge
with these code words being used to keep
things quiet until the family were ready
to make it public on top of this tempers
begin to fray with Harry with the media
continuing to cause tension it's often
being said stories were sold on the
other to play the popularity game which
are rumors that have circulated the
family with every member you also have
the controversial uniform that Harry
wore at the party which caused some
major stirs at the time lastly he brings
up how Harry killed his brother which
hey get that's what you call subtext
guys now the stuff with William and
Kate's family is difficult to confirm
but he does end up leaving to join the
celebration William did attend the
Jubilee in real life with him appearing
on the balcony when the family came out
the show is Elizabeth trying to dissuade
him with Kate also offering an easy
Escape still though he stands there with
her and shows that he wants to stay
strong with his family this would of
course be reflected in how things end up
with Harry with it possibly being
something that they're teasing here now
after the Doom and Gloom of the inquiry
digging up Old Wounds and making William
right a statement the finale is far more
of a celebration of the crown and the
queen centering around Charles and
camiller as well we see as the queen
considers passing the throne over as a
wedding gift visited by CLA Foy and
Olivia Coleman we get no way throne and
the cameos that everyone's been waiting
for the pair remind her of her
responsibilities and in the end she
crumbles up the Q card in which she'd
stand down doesn't even need it the
crowd are loving it tears streaming down
their faces with laughter and the queen
is back we are so back now all of this
is completely made up like obviously
because because of the whole CLA Foy
showing up through a portal thing and
and doing the Avengers tune but in
reality the queen didn't go to the Civil
ceremony nor did she ever write a q card
about stepping down or plan to give up
the crown as a last minute wedding gift
the queen was someone who said to have
seen her life as being in service and
it's not thought that she would have
ever given this up there was always a
thought as well that the queen didn't
really like Camila either but this was
disputed as she did give them her
blessing the queen would of course also
continue her rule until her death during
2022 now what happens next we of course
know from our own history and we also
know we probably won't be getting other
Seasons Creator Peter Morgan actually
intended for the fifth to be the last
with him even saying it was the perfect
place to stop however he later changed
his mind and said that they needed
another to do it justice speaking to the
radio times he stated they' end 20 years
before modern day as it would provide
enough distance to truly understand the
time he also thought it was important to
end in a more dignified way rather than
docu ing all the further controversies
that have since come in an interview
with variety he also talked about how
the final episode changed in the wake of
Queen Elizabeth's death there were
discussions they were going to close out
with her passing but after seeing how it
impacted people in real life they didn't
feel like they could truly capture it
thus they instead tackle it by having
the Queen's funeral plan with pipes
playing sleep de sleep in the end all
there is is the crown which I think is
the message that the ending brings with
it comes glorious purpose and it's a
sacrifice to rule rather than being
something that should be seen as selfish
like Philip says there will never be
another like Elizabeth and our longest
reing Monarch leaves a long Legacy what
happens with the royal family now who
knows but there is the feeling that the
party could be over that again is
something Philip says but whether it
turns out to be the case we'll just have
to see we close out with Elizabeth
imagining her coughing in past versions
and much like her sister heading off in
a moment that symbolizes her death in
the afterlife this is very much
symbolizing her walking off into heaven
which I do feels quite a powerful way to
close out the show just that one final
shot it does stay with you and though
they could have fumbled it I feel it
works well now we've also had rumors of
a spin-off show coming down the line
with that being something that the sun
has reported the radio times has managed
to debunk it but Morgan has stated he
does have an idea however he said that
he wants to do other things first but he
will eventually focus on a prequel
taking place before Elizabeth's Reign
still though he's stuck by the fact that
he wants some distance first so it's
unlikely we'll see this materialize for
a while now as for this season again I
think it kind of carried the dip that
the first part had with the season's
Peak sort of being around all the Diana
stuff though I don't think this is bad
by any means it does have its ridiculous
moments and can be a bit all over the
place with some of the plot lines
there's the dream dream and then bits
where Olivia and Kate are like your mom
died and you're harassed by the press
and scrutinized every moment of the day
but but try being a woman mate cuz you
you haven't got it that bad again seeing
things like that you know you know they
didn't happen in real life and it is a
bit weird for those moments to play out
and kind of break the emotion I think
that this feels like the most dramatized
season in the show with there being
clear creative Liberties being taken
sometimes they work and sometimes they
don't but overall I think fans will
still continue to enjoy this to me it's
kind of going through things we've
explored before a lot like popularity
and whether the Royals are still needed
in society still though these are always
relevant themes but there wasn't quite
the dramatic t ties and dynamism I feel
of being in other Seasons think this
part of the Season feels safe and what
you'd expect with it being a bit flat in
comparison to the other ones that are
released think that if you're in this
deep though that it is worth checking
out and obviously I would love to hear
all your thoughts below please drop a
like on the video and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping me and the team out
now if you want some else to watch you
can see our breakdown of the first part
which will be linked on screen right now
that goes over all the real life things
that happen in that and how they compare
to how they handle them in the show if
not then huge thank you for sing through
the video and without other way I've
been your host Paul You' been the best
I'll see you next time take care
peace